I want to jump to this story from
timcast.com Montana Governor signs Bill
defining male and female governor Greg
gianforte was lobbied by his adult son
to oppose Senate Bill 458 and other
bills regulating gender issues they say
he signed Senate Bill 458 in the law May
19th the bill States term female refers
to a member of the human species who
under normal development has access
Chrome XX chromosomes and produces or
would produce relatively large
relatively immobile gametes or eggs
during her life cycle it has a
reproductive and endocrine system
oriented around the production of those
gametes including an individual who
would otherwise fall within this
definition but for a biological or
genetic condition
Additionally the state will not
recognize mail to meet a member of the
human species who under normal
development has X Y chromosomes and
produces or would produce small mobile
gametes or sperm during his life cycle
and has a reproductive and endocrine
system oriented around the production of
those gametes including an individual
who would otherwise fall within this
definition but for biological or genetic
condition
so I'm curious if they included in this
anything pertaining to intersex because
there there are several different
um genetic uh
circumstances where a person may uh have
X Y chromosomes we totally appear
totally female and that's like Androgen
insensitivity disorder or syndrome or
something like that so someone's
biologically male but their body does
not in any way react to testosterone so
when they're born they look like girls
and they grow up they look like girls
and it's like hey wait a minute that's
actually a guy whose testosterone never
worked and then there's also people
um there's a variety of uh syndromes
where people could be x y y or xxy I'm
wondering how it defines them yeah I
will say however
this is a particularly interesting
considering the transgender rep you know
in in Montana we mentioned mentioned in
the article the bill was one of several
gender related policies passed during a
contentious legislative session
prompting a vitriolic protest from
transgender identifying representative
Zoe Zephyr that led to an official
censure the fact that we've come to the
point where we have to Define male and
female is is fascinating to me and there
was a there's an article I was reading
recently I think it was the daily mail
that referred to a transgender male that
is somebody who is male but wants to be
a woman as a female
and the media does this thing which is
very strange where they will call males
females and females male I think that's
why they have to do this so what happens
is first we say we hear man is a social
construct women is a social construct
you can be a biological male but be a
woman if you're trans that's what the
left argues then they started just once
again changing the words and saying
trans female
now if you're born male but want to be
female they call you transgender female
which is not and never was the actual
description of of what the person was
yeah exactly and so this is something
I've noticed where conservatives are now
shocked that the left has redefined male
and female which is perplexing to me
because why would that be shocking when
they redefine man and woman why would
you think they redefine those words but
they're not going to redefine male and
female and strip them all meaning well
of course they were going to you can't
like retreat into that linguistic
territory we and expect them not to
muddle that up either and we had uh
lands from the serfs the leftist
I said someone asked what is a woman and
he says easy an adult human female and I
said oh okay so trans women are not
women he goes no they are trans women
are female he said yeah I'm just
thinking about Lance that makes no sense
I explained to him that men that
transitioned to be trans women are trans
women and men at the same time they
don't stop being one to become the other
they become both and he was like no
that's not what they think but but he
was telling me like what the current
brainwashing is is that they don't but
the reality is you never stop being
human when you become a trans man or a
trans woman you're still a human you're
still a man and now you're a trans woman
and a man but uh Ian's completely right
he's touching us if you're an adult
human male you're a man and then if you
are transgender you are a trans woman
but you are still an adult human male
well oh sorry I just think that the
definition is pretty good and it does
get after what you say but for a
biological or genetic condition yeah
yeah that would be the things that you
were alluding to uh so you know but
there's the interesting thing there then
is there may be someone who presents
completely as female because of like
Androgen and sensitivity and has spent
their whole life believing they were a
woman only to find out when they're in
their you know late 20s so what does
that mean do they lose protections or
are people gonna I mean I think I I look
forward to the day that we're back
focused on that like
.01.005 of the population I hope that's
where we get back to because right now
we're talking about it to the point
where oh you have to introduce your
five-year-old to this and buy them gear
at Target I mean this is just a crazy
place and it's on on purpose frankly not
for a lot of people that are struggling
with it I think the real question is you
know why are so many people struggling
with it you know so uh you went from in
in 2013 in the United States I think
there were two gender clinics and now
you have hundreds if not thousand plus
of them all over the country like what
happened all of human history you don't
have this now suddenly it's everywhere I
think the real question is why well
there were also just two genders back
then and now there's hundreds across the
country social media is a big factor and
I think endocrine disruptors are big are
a big factor so I think I I I was
wondering this you know I was listening
to some old old rock
and didn't it am I just wrong about this
that rock stars used to be a little bit
older and gruffer and thicker like I'm I
don't know men just seemed manlier back
in the day dirty dirtier definitely
dirtier yeah but maybe that's just how
media you know portrayed people and now
they're trying to change it or something
but there there is a Trope among
Millennials where they're like you watch
these old movies and you're like wait a
minute that dude was 30. they look like
they're 50. why is it that everybody
looks so much younger today yeah I'm
wondering if endocrine disruptors have
been screwing with us for the past
couple of decades the past few
Generations because Plastics are a new
thing for human civilization Plastics
and vaccines I mean if you look at RFK
RFK for you know uh the Democratic
presidential candidate he's talked about
vaccines for a long time you know uh
look I got vaccinated against I was in
the Army I mean I I didn't know that you
could function as an adult without
getting shots until I got out of the
army and my doctor said oh yeah you
don't actually need shots but like every
time I went to see a doctor I was
getting vaccinated against something but
if you look at kids that came up in this
era over the past you know few decades
they've never gone up in an era where
they they didn't have lots of vaccines
some people say it's that I just think
we should have an honest investigation
as to you know what did change I think I
don't I wouldn't want to isolate just
vaccines I think big Pharma in general
the amount of pills medications whatever
you want to call it we're giving kids
more shots than ever we're giving them
more pills than ever we are we've got
chemicals loaded up on our food
something's happening yeah plastics it's
birth control too people don't
acknowledge that there's a lot of excess
estrogen that just gets peed back out
into the water supply I I was thinking
like I learned about amphetamines and
like dare in like third grade and I was
like oh amphetamines are like they get
you going there they get you speed
they're they're nasty drugs like the
Gateway leads you to amphetamines
amphetamines are the dark and then all
of a sudden Adderall it's an amphetamine
and it's like I think it's I think it's
like four different amphetamines or
something like that like it's a
combination and you're actually
considering giving those to children
like you're not but considering they do
yeah so so it my point is when we're
talking about first you know because
there the original subject was male and
female and trans stuff I would not be
surprised if well I will first say it is
a fact look this up there was a birth
control that masculinity masculinized uh
young girls
uh it because of the exposure to this
birth control in women resulted in the
female fetus becoming masculinized and
that we read about it on the show
so birth control is doing this
then we also know that Plastics are
endocrine disruptors that's why use we
use the the glass bottles and uh liquid
death had a funny commercial recently
about people getting plastic shoved in
their bodies to make their like butts
bigger and they're like plastic surgery
or whatever it was funny because they're
they're all about using aluminum cans
out of plastics because Plastics are bad
but I do think a large component is
social pressures which is why we see
typically it's like the overwhelming
majority of trans kids are female
because they're being pressured by
social media but then I do think one of
the reasons we're seeing
some of this may just be people are
suffering from endocrine disruption
their bodies aren't producing the right
hormones and the bright right levels and
this is not some right-wing conspiracy
theory right the data has shown that
testosterone has been decreasing for the
past few decades now this is a real oh
yeah I was just learning about
apparently when a man sees a woman comes
into contact with a woman his
testosterone spikes by 20 roughly this
is some some things I just learned I
don't know if it's real or not but it
sounds cool and so I'm wondering if all
this interaction with women digitally
like watching movies with women in it
and watching porn for instance is
getting this like the body stops
producing the testosterone Spike because
it's not getting the reciprocity from
the woman so it realizes like okay she's
not really there she's not really there
and when you see a woman in real life
she's not really there like we're
becoming adapted that's not had this
testosterone Spike I hear what you're
saying but I feel like that's way too uh
there's too many leaps happening it's a
long shot if anything
looking at all these women would
increase men's tests you would think so
but then if it happens over and over and
over and over and you're not getting the
the value of the testosterone the body
might just stop doing it because it's
like well there's at least a correlation
between wealth and uh poverty right so
if you look what's going what's
different in wealthy countries than in
poor countries and there are so many
different things but I do think that
that it'd be worthwhile subject but
today I mean look this uh this uh
professor at Brown she she got canceled
she was one of the first cancel culture
people in it I mean she's an atheist
professor at Brown and she started going
well what happens with like okay there's
someone who's transgender and then in
their peer group once one person
identifies as transgender lots of other
people in that school or in that peer
group start to identify as transgender
too and she coined it sudden onset
gender dysphoria because she wanted to
investigate it and gave it a label but
the whole APA uh you know Psychological
Association went after her canceled her
got her unpublished and everything she'd
written scholarly journals and she was
going at it from an academic perspective
they've literally worked to kill any
serious academic study into yeah what
does explain this and it was just an
intellectual curiosity like well why is
it all of a sudden spreading to other
people versus you know the biological or
genetical issues that were referenced in
the Montana law yeah well this is also
interesting too right because they'll
argue that this idea of social contagion
is also a far-right conspiracy theory
but the president of wpath which is like
the leading transgender activism
organization on the planet has
acknowledged that social contagion is
driving in some part the massive surge
of kids who are now identifying as trans
yeah you also call it peer pressure
that's what you call in the 80s well
isn't it so crazy that they would even
try to get away with saying teens aren't
doing things because of peer pressure of
course they are dude how could you say
there's this one category of behavior
that's immune to peer pressure or among
teens that's insane way for a kid to
take control of their parents and their
their the law basically control from
their parents yeah if a 14 year old can
be like now because I say this you all
have to bow to me and I'm 13 but like
what a power surge for a young human to
be able to be like all I gotta do is say
I'm trans and then I can depending on
the state the doctors will be alike come
right in and we'll have those old boys
removed you can get like teachers fired
if they don't don't agree with you you
can get politicians like it's crazy but
psychotic power is involved yes no it's
true why is jump in social standing
massively which is what young people
want there's more social status it's not
so much about social status and Ian's
point is talking about Authority and
control but they're the system they're
the same right the more social status
you have the more control you have over
the system no I just like the most
social status you could possibly have is
to be in full control socially and
legally I disagree um social status is
like celebrity where people want to just
give you things be around you and you
know in terms of authority you could be
the most hated person in the world but
everyone gives you stuff but I would say
I would say that somebody who is in a
position of legal Authority but is hated
has a lower social status than someone
who's in a position of legal Authority
and who everybody lies I'm saying that
they're they both play a role in Social
Status like if our lawsuit for sure
women they have a higher Social Status
now like to a certain degree you can
argue that people are attracted to
someone of great governmental wealth but
there's a balance yeah if you are the
ugliest most out of shape smelliest you
know dude living in a basement all right
I get it you can you can Ian you can go
out well in New York and you can dress
up in in historical con period according
to New York law
and they are forced to give you what you
want you can force a massive
multi-billion dollar Corporation to do
whatever you want that doesn't mean you
have any good social status yeah and
that's kids in general have no social
issues actually that people have no
social status are going and exploiting
the system well but I would say that if
there are laws that are written that
tell people they're not allowed to
disagree with you their social status in
that right legal system privileges
groups of people everybody's privileged
off the status yeah 100 so if the law
says anyone can do whatever they want
there's no social status yeah but my
argument is not that social stuff I
understand that there has to be a
differential like some people have to be
lower in Social Status than other for
others for like the legal question to
apply my point is simply that when one
group of people are set aside by the law
and said they have special privileges
that increases social status but I'm
talking about how the law does not
protect a group of people it's random
the New York City law says anything you
do is protected it's literally anything
so the the the a homeless person of no
social status has control in a system if
they choose to that's not social status
that's just a broken system I'm not so
my initial response to what Ian was
saying is that creating these quote
unquote transgender protections boosts
the social status of people who have
that identity like that identified label
what I'm trying to clarify is that's not
the case you don't think so you don't
think that that boosts their social
status the fact that they can go around
telling people they have to use their
pronouns or that employers
do it for anything right so the law
doesn't say you have to use someone's
she her he and pronouns it says anyone
who says anything has to be respected
I'm just gonna say in New York if you're
if you're a black man and defend uh
anything Conservative then you must be a
white supremacist right so I mean well I
do think there's something I don't know
whether it's called social status or
whatever but you have all these people
that it's like if you step out of what
they're you know one of my colleagues
referred to somebody we don't need any
more Brown faces that aren't Brown
voices or black faces that aren't black
voices or things like that and it's like
well you know Tim Scott's like
I'm not supposed to talk uh you know and
and so there is this kind of I don't
know heresy code I don't know whether
it's status or whatever but kind of this
whole kind of woke culture has got its
own heresy code there is no doctrine of
grace over there you cross the line
you're canceled and so I think to your
point yeah there's a but that's highly
selective in terms of where you would
even have status I mean yeah some Perry
some areas is not going to your status
goes even worse and maybe even in Peril
when they say that anyone can dress in a
historical period costume they're not
privileging transgender people they are
basically saying anyone can wear and
dress and be called whatever they demand
and you must adhere to it
if they said if someone who is
traditionally male appears in
non-traditional you know or appears as
female presents in female stereotypical
clothing using female names you cannot
just go down this basis that would be
outlining just trans people but New
York's law it's the weirdest thing I've
ever seen it says you can dress in
historical period like those words
actually appear in the law which means
you could dress up like a pirate in New
York City and say I'm pirate gender and
it's protected not even asking and your
Pirates could be R and matey and it's
that's not a group of pirates are not
protected but they are now that's my
point yeah Pirates are not protected
gender in New York City you are a
privileged class this is something that
Jordan Peterson said in response to bill
c-16 which I thought was a great
observation which is that what a lot of
these protection laws do is they
enshrine
um a person's fashion Choice as like a
legally protected identity so I'm
wondering could I go in in chainmail or
or like plate yes yes I identify as a
knight from the Middle Ages so so look
I've brought this up time and time again
where the lawyers told me and I will get
laughed out of the courtroom but the New
York civil rights law Set uh Human
Rights Commission says historical period
I have no idea why that's that's kind of
insane it's not gender identified but it
literally says it meaning you can put on
a full plate armor and be like these are
my clothes we talked about this a while
ago right yeah and that's right we
actually had a lawyer on the show and
they were basically saying that I think
we were joking about wearing a fursuit
or something and saying like that and he
said I mean legally yeah but you'd
probably get laughed out of the
courtroom well no I talked to I talked
to several human rights lawyers who told
me that I so this is 2019 or whatever I
call a bunch of lawyers and I said what
would happen if someone did this and
they said everyone knows the point of
the law you'd get left out of the
courtroom
the problem is now is they've expanded
it there's there's there's there's no
way this makes sense when they added the
words historical period because now it's
you can dress up like like I mentioned
you know put on a safari costume and a
big white fake beard and call yourself
the colonel and they can't they that's
protected the historical period is
protected yeah I think at some point you
know a lot of the country's just like
yeah we're gonna move on you guys go
ahead and do that
um and we're not going to go along with
it and that's kind of where this whole
effort to counter that it goes with Bud
Light like man we're just you do it go
do your thing as an adult whatever you
are but I'm not drinking Bud Light
anymore we talked about that last night
how do you see like the value and
differential between political power and
I guess private sector power like well
there's obviously some sort of
correlation between power and money
right so uh I don't think that's new to
our culture or any other place around
the world but you know if you look at if
you look at um you know influence uh you
know at some point cultural influence
really drives the politics I mean a lot
of times people say in a fun functioning
democracy you get the government you
deserve you get what you voted for and
people will get frustrated by what we
get and it's it's hard to believe that
you know you could have you know
Marjorie Taylor green uh when 80 of the
vote in her district and you know um
you know AOC when 80 of the vote in her
district and people love them both but
they're so very different and I think
that's gets to like our constitution
actually is designed to have that kind
of flexibility but somehow in the era
that we're in there's this idea that
everything has to be federalized and I
think that's the problem it's like yeah
you can actually do your thing in New
York and do it your way Ohio we're not
going to do that probably uh and you
know if you really want to you could
maybe do it in a certain area but we're
not going to change our laws like New
York did and Texas may do it totally
different but if you want to make it all
one big federal policy and just cram it
down your throat that's the tension
people are trying to seize power in
Washington and impose their will on
everyone else yeah I think one massive
problem with the direction the United
States has gone and really over the past
hundred years is to create an analogy
we've gone from a neighborhood to an
apartment building so when you're in a
neighborhood everyone has their own
house they have their own lawn they can
make decisions about their house they
can add something on to it subtract
something from it have a guard did not
have a garden on chickens whatever it is
right in your all houses you're all in
the neighborhood you all have the same
zip code but you're able to make
decisions about your own property
there's some sovereignty there might be
an HOA that puts some limitations on it
but overall you can make your own choice
for your own property now it's like the
United States has become a condominium
and each state is its own little condo
and you're able to make decisions and
it's technically your own property as a
state or as the governor of a state or
as the people of a state but you're not
fully Sovereign because
there's a certain pattern you have to
follow so that you don't move outside of
the status quo of what is like
architecturally sound for that building
but Ronda Santos was able to tell him to
shove it during the covid attempted
shutdowns so you would still consider
him in the apartment complex but just
like I would say he's trying to make
moves out yeah I would say I would say
that like he's sort of starting to shift
the Paradigm because what happens is
when you have an incredibly strong
federal government
each state becomes more affected by
decisions made in other states in a way
where they historically were not when
the government didn't have as much
oversight or when the federal government
didn't have as much oversight and so
what I think DeSantis is doing and again
analogies limp and where this one falls
apart is that we can actually you know
disassemble the condominium and put
people back onto their own property and
I think Governors like DeSantis move us
in that direction by pulling away from
federal oversight thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time